beginning oim the get up roll so this is
another great practice that can really
help you and your Kim practice in the
beginning it begins with the
rock where I tuck my chin herb my spine
and allow myself to rock backwards and
then forward from there though I'm going
to begin to get up so the practice
progresses like this
this will help you learn to get up from
your rolls as I begin to progress I can
also practice a hip switch so each time
I go down I'm going to switch my hips
which will enable me to come up on a new
foot it's like
this my left foot's
forward
and my right foot's forward this is a
great way to start to develop strengthen
your core to help you get up quickly
after your roll I'm Christopher hind
thanks for
watching